如果奶奶想给你，
奶奶就得强势，
奶奶就得主持大局，
奶奶就得上村委会开会，
完了之后让他们白纸黑字签下来，
这个房子到时候登记到你的名儿，
你不要去参和这个事儿，
要让奶奶去，
趁着奶奶现在有力气去走这个事儿，
如果说你的父母不同意的话，
那奶奶也干不成这事儿。
我现在我有大概三个问题吧，
一个是家里有一套房子，
我想说就是这个归属的问题，
然后还有就是我现在是23岁，
三颗，
我是家里领养的，
是爷爷奶奶带大的，
房子是我爷爷的，
但是他现在去世了，
我想着说这个房子我不想让房子属于我爸妈，
这房子是爷爷奶奶的，
爷爷奶奶去世了，
奶奶没去世，
爷爷去世了，
然后这房子现在是没有过户啥的，
他是宅基地，
然后属于我爷爷，
但是我们没有去更名，
所以我不知道这个到底算谁的，
因为我爸爸妈妈都不是很好，
所以我奶奶想说，
这个房子直接给我就是怎么能做到，
那必须是你的父母同意，
你父母要是不同意的话是做不到的，
因为在法律上来说啊，
爷爷去世了，
他的房产是由他的配偶。
子女来继承的，
只要说他子女还在，
就楼上村子女，
如果奶奶想给你，
奶奶就得强势，
奶奶就得主持大局，
奶奶就得上村委会开会，
完了之后让他们白纸黑字签下来，
这个房子到时候登记到你的名儿，
你不要去参考这个事儿，
要让奶奶去，
趁着奶奶现在有力气去走这个事儿，
如果说你的父母不同意的话，
那奶奶也干不成这事儿，
因为我妈妈是有精神疾病的，
我爸爸算是正常人吧，
但他就是反应迟钝的，
他小时候也是有发烧烧坏过，
我爸爸的工资是我奶奶管的，
但是我妈的工资就是一直是给家里的，
我从小到大她就是没有给过我任何钱什么的，
如果奶奶强势的话，
奶奶抓紧时间去做这个事情，
要求你爸你妈来同意这个事儿，
来签字，
所以明白最好是跟村委会的村领导，
就是我们之前分房子的时候，
我妈妈娘家那边有过来闹过，
就他们也想要房子，
这样就闹得很难看，
就是我们家拿的是独栋的宅基地的，
也是村里那边建议我们说如果拿3套房子，
我可能确实会被他们拿走，
我们是拿到一个独栋的房子，
但是奶奶这一头呢，
我觉得要提前，
举个例子啊，
说这个房子我假设啊假。
这房子是值100万，
按钱来算，
好算账啊，
那么爷爷去世了，
爷爷的50万发生了继承，
奶奶的50万还在奶奶的手里，
爷爷这50万是由爷爷的配偶、
父母、
子女来平分，
如果爷爷只有偶，
配偶还在，
子女就一个的话，
那么奶奶还能分到25万，
剩下的25万才是你父亲来分的啊，
这样的话，
奶奶手上总共是75万，
奶奶一定要提前立好遗嘱，
这75万是归你来继承的，
这个是法律上没毛病，
就算说整栋楼没法给你一个人，
那么奶奶所占比75也可以都确定给你一个人，
这个是能做到的，
这奶奶最好是立遗嘱，
还有这个遗嘱呢，
最好是在当地请个明白人，
就是学过法律的，
请当地的村委村长啊支书啊做个见证，
好吧，
好的，
然后我的养父他是有骚扰我的朋友，
我就是想说，
有没有什么方法能不影响我，
倒是能让他老实一点，
你和你的朋友都不应该在这个房子里面再住下去了，
应该出去打工去，
在外面找工作去，
不要回到这个家里，
我自己是放不下我奶奶，
但是我奶奶又比较关心他的儿子，
那不行，
就是家里装上监控，
明确告诉我你的这个养父。
家里到处都装着监控，
不要做一些丢人现眼的事儿，
然后我的妈妈她这些钱都是给了她娘家，
她现在快退休了，
他的爸爸妈妈如果来闹的话，
我们就是可以直接跟他们说，
这些房子什么钱都是他们拿不到的嘛，
从法律上来说的话，
他们也不沾什么边儿，
因为就算你的爸爸继承了那25%，
你爸爸还有一个权利，
他可以放弃继承呢，
作为配偶的话，
确实沾不上什么边儿，
如果你自己有本事的话啊，
将来自己有本事了，
可以把奶奶接出去生活呀，
我现在就是待业吧，
我之前有工作两年，
就是刚毕业，
算的话是四五千，
我自己也存了2万左右，
家里的话，
如果我买房子，
他们最多最多全部拿出来就是15万，
能给我的是15万，
我自己拿的话，
我只有2万，
然后后面我想就是说找一个倒班的工作，
钱能赚的多一点，
然后以后我爸妈养老的问题，
就是怎么办呢？
我不是很想管他们了，
如果他们有退休金，
像你妈妈她退休了，
他有退休金，
从法律上来说的话，
他也没有办法问你要赡养费，
你的爸爸有退休金吗？
他现在还是在厂里上班，
有养老金的话，
他就没有办法问你要赡养费，
我觉得你现在这个状态的话，
可能不太适。
和买房子，
姑娘你应该是多学本事，
多到处去见见世面，
看看哪里挣钱更多，
而不是说就框在哪儿，
就买个房子就框在这儿了。
我之前因为我奶奶和我妈经常两天一大吵，
就是各种吵架，
我有想过就是带我奶奶出去住，
但是因为房子是爷爷奶奶的，
奶奶也就是说不想把房子留给他们两个人，
可以卖呀，
农村的房子也可以卖，
嗯，
好，
假设说不想这房子留给这俩人的话，
比如说这房子卖了100万，
给你的养父25万，
奶奶拿着75万，
这是应该应份的，
本来就是该这么分的，
对吧？
然后换个地方生活也是可以的，
好的好，
就这样啊，
记得点赞关注哦。